Soll pluto jetzt wieder ein planet werden
2006 hatte er ja seinen planeten status verloren die internationale astronomische union
hatte ihre kriterien bezüglich des planeten status geändert jetzt wird die ganze diskussion und pluto wieder neu entfacht denn ein
astronomie team hat fakten zusammengetragen die entscheidung von 2006 in frage stellen also jetzt doch alles ganz anders
klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Das war wirklich eine mehr als denkwürdige änderung unseres sonnensystems doch die neuen kriterien der internationalen astronomischen union iau
aus dem jahr 2006 ließen keinen zweifel
pluto war raus aus der planeten riege denn seit zwölf jahren regelt die eu in einer neuen definition welche kriterien
himmelskörper erfüllen müssen um als planet zu gelten die drei kriterien sind die folgenden erstens die himmelskörper müssen ein
gestirn umkreisen zweitens sie müssen durch ihre eigene schwerkraft
abgerundet sein dritter die orbit sollte
freigeräumt von anderen objekten seien schon damals gab es heftige kritik an der entscheidung vor allem an dem teil der
fordert dass ein planet seine umlaufbahn völlig gesäubert haben müsste denn dies sei selbst bei der erde dem mars oder
dem jupiter nicht der fall in deren umlaufbahn nämlich mehrere
zehntausende asteroiden kreisen ein forschungsteam aus florida hat jetzt in einem artikel mehrere argumente
zusammengetragen die die definition der iaa und komplett in frage stellen dann so findet einer der
beteiligten forscher einen stern harte worte ich denke die eu hat sich damit wirklich
blamiert sie haben ein problem für sich selbst und für die astronomie produziert das team aus den usa hat für ihre argumentation
wissenschaftliche arbeiten aus den letzten 200 jahren analysiert und nach dem begriff planet durchforstet das ergebnis lediglich
eine arbeit habe das zentrale kriterium der
eu-definition korrekt genutzt dagegen hat das ziel mehr als 100 beispiele gefunden in denen der begriff
planet von den jeweiligen autorinnen und autoren so eingesetzt wurde dass er gegen die geltenden definition verstößt vor allem das dritte kriterium
stößt den verfassern und verfasserin
artikels auf die definition der eu führe dazu dass gleiche himmelskörper anders definiert werden bzw
eingestuft werden und das einzig und allein aufgrund der anzahl ihrer begleiter in den umlaufbahnen ein großes problem dass forscher
stellen an dem beispiel der erde erläutert denn selbst unser heimmarkt daneben wäre demnach in der pluto
umlaufbahn kein planet mehr denn in einer bestimmten zone im sonnensystem macht es die hohe anzahl an brocken und möglich die großen
umlaufbahn ganz frei zu halten so das argument des us
forschungsteams konkret befindet sich diese region des sonnensystems etwa auf der höhe von uranus und neptun
dazu stern in einem interview mit space.com auch die erde würde das nicht schaffen das gebiet wäre einfach zu groß
das bedeutet aber auch im umkehrschluss und das müsst ihr euch ja vorstellen selbst wenn alle neuen planeten unseres sonnensystems
zwillinge der erde wären würden sie nach der definition der eu eben nicht alle als planeten gelten dazu der autor man hätte neuen
identische objekte von denen man sechs einen planeten nennen würde und drei nicht
das ist ungefähr so als wenn man sagen würde ich nenne eine kuh nur dann eine kuh wenn sie nicht in einer herde ist
doch das ist nicht das einzige argument des forschungsteams gegen wie neue
definition des planeten status es argumentiert dass der orbit vom planeten und eben auch die menge seiner begleiter
dynamisch ist deswegen sein dieses kriterium völlig
ungeeignet ihn für die definition eines planeten status heranzuziehen dazu heißt es in der studie
sie sind daher keine grundlegende eigenschaft eines himmelskörpers sondern beschreiben nur sein momentanes umfeld auch der begriff des
freiräumen im dritten kriterium sei sehr ungenau was sie damit genau meint bleibe offen so die studie
zitat sie haben nicht festgelegt was sie genau mit freiräumen des ortes meinen damit das kriterium wörtlich nimmt gebe es gar keine planeten
denn keiner ist allein auf seinem orbit und tatsächlich viele planeten wie etwa die erde oder auch der jupiter haben begleiter in ihrer umlaufbahn
trojaner genannt das dritte kriterium der planeten definition ist laut des forschungsteams also durchweg kritisch zu sehen
die studie fordert jetzt auf dieses kriterium zu verzichten stattdessen sei die beurteilung anderer merkmale wichtig die die tatsächlichen
wichtigen merkmale eines himmelskörpers
beschreibt wie zum beispiel das zweite kriterium der eu-definition die abrundung der himmelskörper durch ihre eigene schwerkraft ein
meilenstein in der entwicklung eines kleineren himmelskörpers so das forschungsteam und somit durchaus
charakteristisch für den planeten status denn dadurch werde eine aktive geologie des objektes
losgetreten und genau dies sei bei pluto der fall eine atmosphäre mit wolken dünen und
eisvulkanen beherbergt der herabgestuften experiment zu geben auch fließende
gletscher um vielleicht sogar einen flüssigen ozean unter seiner eiskruste
enthüllt hatten dass daten der nasa raumsonde new horizons dazu das team aus florida
pluto ist damit dynamischer und lebendiger als der mars der einzige planet der eine noch komplexere geologie besitzt ist die erde
das fazit der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler all diese fakten könnte man nicht so stehen lassen stattdessen sei es höchste zeit die eu planeten definition wieder zu ändern
die entscheidung von 2006 sei durch personen getroffen worden die nicht wirklich ahnung vom fach hätten so das team der studie und weiter
wir schlagen vor den konsens über eine planetarische taxonomie nicht über den
wissenschaftlichen prozess einer abstimmung zu erreichen sondern durch auswertung der
wissenschaftlichen literatur und diskussion eine reaktion der beiden wissenschaftler die die entscheidung von 2006 maßgeblich
mitbestimmten die gibt es auch schon mike brown vom california institute of technology
der sich bei twitter auch pluto killer nennt zeigt sich überhaupt nicht beeindruckt ebenso sein kollege konstantin
bettingen er fordert ein ende des streits wichtig sei doch weiter zu den eigenschaften der himmelskörper zu forschen zitat
unwichtig dagegen wie wir sie nennen so schreibt der auf twitter hört sich wie ein
rückzugsgefecht an und vor allem ist dass wir wissenschaft etwas untypisch so
unwissenschaftlich vorzugehen liegt ein wenig den verdacht nahe als wären die übeltäter damals wohl wissend so
schlampig gewesen ja und wenn ihr zu diesem und zu allen anderen themen kein video mehr verpassen wollt dann habe ich am ende des videos
einen kleinen trick für euch jetzt aber eine kleine sensation
keine werbung mehr auf pixel mehr schon angefangen immer mehr videos sind werbefrei dank eurer hilfe
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung vor einem video ab werdet also
mitglied hier unter dem video draufklicken und ihr bekommt noch exklusive extras wie des livestreams und noch ein paar weitere privilegien
für einen kleinen beitrag und der trick der geht so wenn er immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp nur da
bekommt ihr das aktuelle video deutlich vor allen anderen von mir persönlich auf euer handy
einfach hier draufklicken und darunter geht es weiter mit auch dafür draufklicken ende des
sonnensystems fotografiert da geht es um die mission der sonde new horizons bis dann
bleibt dran